hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
today we're here with another video so
just ended off my last Noob with the
mail episode that was number 19 on the
big number 20 right here uh we just
ended with 245 mil and one five eight
seven total levels so we're gonna go
ahead and try to progress that as much
as we can we have a kbd task coming up
at some point I also want to go ahead
and get my uh runecrafting up just so
that I can do certain things in game
um because lavaroons are cool as [__]
right now and now that you can shift
click and empty room pouches it sounds
like a time to be alive so pretty
excited for that I have 148 mil right
there might get to do some merching
though oh finally done with the trip
don't mind this death pile I was just
kind of afking but I didn't get a whole
lot off this task
um only real thing I'm ever really
looking for is the pet but uh
in due time my friends in due time we'll
do one extra kill might as well since
I'm here and I have the supplies for it
back again time for another task so
chaos Elemental Es as you guys know I do
love me a good chaos Elemental task
we'll take 35 I think this will pull us
up to around 140 to 150 KC hopefully we
can grab ourselves a pet
are you kidding me I just died I didn't
get my protect item prayer on in time
because I was hopping worlds and I saw a
clan
and that means I lost my imbued Slayer
helm
and if anyone wants to know why this all
happened that's because in one of the
worlds that I was logged into I tried
luring the chaos Elemental four times
every time I got unlucky enough to where
he teleported me away and I got pissed
in hop worlds from there I saw a clan
that was up there in the wilderness and
I kind of was just looking to see what
was going on I figured maybe there's
like a bunch of people were just
fighting each other and so I was just
looking and then by the time I knew it
someone had hopped on to me as you guys
can see
um dead just like that and yeah so now I
definitely hate myself and I have to go
get another Slayer helmet viewed finally
we finally did it I hate this so much I
hate that I have to re [__] get one
of these man uh also got 83 attack along
the way I guess so it's kind of cool but
at the same time pretty pissed off that
that happened really really just took up
a lot of time for no reason nice loaned
out of D Warhammer to um a friend Kevin
140k profit on the merch finally
finished up my chaos Elemental task
obviously nothing much going on there we
did get an extra 5K Slayer XP but not at
all efficient anyway go ahead and get
ourselves 179 cow fights oh man slayer's
killing me man all right so I've been
merging some arcanes it's been going
really well figured I'd kind of throw
you guys in on this basically what I've
been doing is I bought an Arcane Spirit
Shield at one point for 132.5 the same
price so this one then sold it for this
which was the 405k profit and then I
bought another and sold another bring us
up to about 800k profit then I
accidentally sold in just sold one
because I typed in the wrong number
however it showed me that I had more of
a profit in the future so I then went
off this price lost 150k there so I mean
it kind of sucks but that put us at 650k
in total so from there I end up buying
one and selling one but she has just
another 600k so up to about 1.2 mil I
buy another and sell another another
600k so that's 1.8 I buy and sell
another 2.4 mil buy and sell another
three mil and now I'm about to buy and
sell and now they're bringing us up to
about 3.6 mil I think I'm gonna hit my
limit on arcanes but the merging of them
tonight has been a success hopefully we
can kind of replicate this in the future
going forward as we get closer and
closer to the release of The Inferno
when items just start to get really
drastically changed in the GE finally
finish off the Cal fight it's kind of
been putting this one off for a while
time to get another task
great bursting task really happy about
that one
so I'm kind of working on a merch right
now where I go ahead and just Crush all
these birds nests I think I can make
about a 200 GP profit off of each maybe
250 so ultimately just coming here and
having them all crushed for 150k seems
worth it to me
um because 3 000 of them actually will
take me a decent amount of time so I'd
rather just save all that get back to
Slayer and sell on these while I can
we've been merging a lot of bludgeons
for around 180k profit as you guys can
see this is one that's one another one
so in total we've merged I believe eight
for around 150 to 180k per one well not
eight probably around seven I think this
is the eighth one so we've made
somewhere around 1.4 mil or so like
between 1.2 1.4 mil in total off
merching these which is really nice I'm
really happy with that and on top of
that there was kind of this weird thing
with the bird's nest as you guys can see
um I was able to buy 3000 earlier
basically there's around a 210 GP margin
and the sell price was six four nine
five I lowered it to six for 494 and
they all sold instantly it's pretty
crazy so in total we've made probably
close to two mil in this little bit
merging now one thing I am really
terrified about is this third age robe
um it's an item that two weeks ago is
worth 15 mil however it shot up to 25
mil right now and I can apparently merge
it for around 2.3 mil if I'm able to buy
one however I think the reason it has
such a big margin is because people are
scared to even touch it since it might
just drop instantly and here we go going
to go ahead and talk to the king this
should be the end of regicide regicide
is a quest that I've been putting on for
a while because I was hoping I'd get 71
agility beforehand So then whenever I
got to do Zora I wouldn't be inefficient
about it however it's about time we do
some zorres so regicide is done I think
we're gonna go ahead and get some kills
now that's exciting it's exciting good
times good times
and here we are decided I'd go ahead and
finish roving elves as well from what I
can see you need a crystal bow for a
master clue requirement so I may as well
may as well go for the bow so give me
the bow and that should be the quest all
right come on buddy there we go 10 000
strength one Quest Point really just
wanted to do that to kind of get it out
of the way is a cool little Quest I
figured I could just go ahead and do but
now we're gonna get on into Zora and
here comes the first kill of Zora didn't
even have to get to the Jad phase this
account is so nice there it is kill
number one 159 kill time not a bad loot
but uh yeah first the grind let's get it
going first two kills of profit snake
this is going to be enjoyable just hit
50kc bit of a weird drop too too fast
but nothing much to see so far just your
average loot doing pretty good probably
try to go to 100 within the next little
bit that is ridiculous
um I guess we're only at 57 KC but this
is my first four kill trip and honestly
with me even bringing a rune pouch dark
Bow like imbued heart
to only have I think I have 15 food and
I was able to get four kills that is
just insane and here we go so
I have a little collection if you guys
are not aware of alcohol and uh Susie
just went ahead and got 99 cooking so I
appreciate it man thanks a lot congrats
on the cooking level oh man I messed
that one up but thanks a lot man and
there we go finally finished off a
little bit of Zora um I had 50 teleport
Scrolls so I figured I'd go through all
of them and uh yeah 157 KC now so we are
getting up there I think I'm gonna stop
for a little bit just to work on a video
but I'm gonna go ahead and price check
what we have so far in loot here we go
so time to price check there is about
100K worth of stuff in the bank that I
just couldn't get out for this inventory
along with I think around three Spirit
tree seeds which is pretty cool I need
those eventually in the future but I was
gonna get them anyways at one point uh
but yeah this is what we got from about
150 kills now granted there will be some
stuff missing and I obviously did use
supplies to get this so just take that
into account there's around 17
now that's a really good profit I mean
I'm happy with it the overall profit I
mean I spent 1.5 mil in total on the
Scrolls themself they got a little
cheaper which is nice
um I probably spent around two to three
mil and other stuff
um so I mean it's pretty decent made
around 13 mil off of that or so so I
will definitely take that however we
didn't make a whole lot merging on the
side because last night I bought a din's
bulwark for 22 mil and then today sold
off for 19.5 so
but this one I tried to buy because I
think it's going to go back up but I
think it already has since this offer
has been in here for a while oh good
work on his end to be honest though
um now we're kind of in this dangerous
territory where we don't yep that was
that was what I was talking about
so there goes that
um we lost a DH set that's fine with me
it's like two mil maybe three but that's
the last time we ever doing that that
moment when you log into a world and all
you see in your public chat is people
complimenting your videos thinking that
it's you because you're not looking and
then you scroll up
and you see tour Vesta then you get sad
here we are merging as always and uh
yeah so as you guys can see that's about
where I died I was mid-merch I was also
merging while doing P gang and if that's
not one of the most efficient things
I've ever seen I don't know what is but
dexterous prayer scroll I bought for
101.5 sold off for 102.5 so made a mill
there made another mill on another merge
and currently I'm trying to make a third
mill on a merch currently I believe I
should be able to still sell it off so
I've made two mil thus far about to make
three hopefully and on top of that I've
had three armadillo chest plate merches
for 300K each so in total I've merged
2.9 mil however if this sells it's 3.9
and hopefully I can keep merching these
to get a decent amount of money and now
it's the morning so I did end up selling
off some stuff which is really nice
um magic seeds yesterday ended up buying
with the intention of having somebody
else put them into saplings but after
realizing that I it's a pretty big ask I
mean I was going to give him a cut of
the profit but I decided just to leave
it be I didn't make any money off these
I sold them all off just for a No Gain
No No loss nothing
um as far as the last armadill chest
plate that we had
um I did end up doing I think probably
about another merch last night so I
think I made another 300K and I made
another 100K on this merch and I still
managed to sell off this deck scroll
which was really nice because whenever I
went to bed
um the merch was telling me that I would
be able to like
at the time I would lose 500k if I
actually sold it off for the highest
price but overnight I was lucky enough
to be able to sell it off for a Mel
Gaine so we are up to 170 mil cash I
know for a lot of you that this could be
a very hard thing to do and that is deal
with the greater neck reel but all I do
is I just Camp my prayer I just can't my
blood barrage spell and uh you should be
able to gain back enough Health that
you'll be taking from the little minions
in the time that you end up killing it
but there we go got a totem top so let's
continue though I'll be on my way here
in a second boy and here we go done with
the tasks I'm going to go ahead and
price check everything that we ended up
getting back so not too bad of a task I
was averaging 76k Slayer XP per hour and
I was there for a little over an hour I
think with 240 kills and the bracelets
of Slaughter so pretty good XP also
about 250k magic XP per hour but there
we go 1.6 mil definitely covers the
runes that I was using so that's really
nice now time for another task 168 fire
Giants AFK there we go actually was
forced to get favor for the first time
on this account and the first time on
either of my accounts now so we have 5.6
in favor pretty uh disgusting if you
look at this it's just it's a lot of
stuff that I have to do that I haven't
done yet uh there's a quest apparently
now they can give you I think 25 right
off the bat and then double the rest so
I'll finally get down into it get that
Talisman at some point but yeah this was
kind of annoying and there we go hard
clue scroll completed finally finally we
get something 370k that's nice I'll take
it now an easy clue just doing all the
clues man oh my God I guess I mean
that's not bad
for easy clue this was this was probably
the longest kill I've ever had here like
it took me so long and uh we are not
rewarded sadly all right so I messed
this up in the previous recording so
just wanted to go back through it at
this point it's already gone away but I
merged a dexterous scroll for one mil on
top of that I've been marching Dragon
claws for about 450k margin as you guys
can see right here down here we have
three and up here we just have a whole
list of them so in total I've merged
seven declaws for 450k margin which
comes out to around three mil made off
of Dragon claws along with the mill off
the deck scroll too easy too easy some
dumb people are kind of getting in on
this merch right now for some reason the
Gilded full Helm the most recent one was
bought for eight mil no clue why but I
went ahead and made some money off this
and I'll see if I can make any more uh I
did not sell off two of these I don't
know why it's showing like that but as
you guys can see I bought a gilded armor
set for 5.3 mil and I sold it off and
pieces for this is 1.3 add that on and
that brings it up to 4.4 so I sold it
off for 6.4 mil which means I made 1.1
mil almost in total just by buying one
of these and obviously I'm going to try
to do it again at least as long as I can
and hopefully screw over whoever's
buying these gilded Helms so let me go
ahead and do it again and I'll be back
in a second all right so this time I was
not able to sell off the helm at least
for an insane uh at least for an insane
price like I did before but I'll go
ahead and still just list it up for two
mil because there's no harm in it worse
comes the worst I package it back up as
a set sell it for maybe a 50k margin and
if it does end up working out I make a
mill on a gilded Helm so alright so
since I went ahead and showed you guys
that last clip I did end up buying
another I did end up buying and selling
on another three Helms which means I
made about three mil in total off of
that I still apparently can sell them I
think some Duke put in a pretty decent
offer that one didn't insta sell so now
we know that that's not going to work
but one yep see just sold there we go
that's what I'm looking for
in the last like four minutes I've made
damn close to like four mil just off
buying and selling these like it has
been insane I just keep buying them for
5.4 unsetting them and then I end up
selling off most everything for about a
mil under
and then keeping the helm which I can
sell for two mil in total then giving me
a mill profit and yeah it's just been
going non-stop at this point the Helms
keep selling and as long as they keep
selling I'll keep doing this I do not
care like I don't know if that one's
gonna sell but I'll answer sell all this
and we'll give it a second and hopefully
it sells another one what the hell we
just got a champion scroll from fire
Giants
I didn't expect that at all that really
even thought about that that's cool
though hell yeah and haven't done a task
for a while but here we go
I mean it's not terrible I guess but
I'll do it well I'm impatient I decided
actually to go against it it's not a bad
task especially in the catacombs it's
pretty AFK since you can attack like
five blood felt at a time but I'm just
not feeling it that's fine it's quick
another little donation of alcohol shout
out life stalker thank you man and done
with the sucrose task so
please just a boss to ask oh my no I'm
not I'm not doing it
I refuse to do fire Giants
I'll do necros all right guys so we went
ahead and did a little bit of merging
last night as you do and uh yeah I'll
kind of just quickly go over most of
this I ended up selling off the Gilded
Fulham wasn't able to sell it for two
mil again but that was good profit while
I was there uh this Arcane merge for
300K the spectral bought and sold but it
took a long time and I was like a 200k
profit 300 on this D Warhammer another
300 and like 70 on this one 370 on both
I guess and then this dins will work we
merged for 1.3 mil the next one we merch
for about 900k and then the next one
closer to 600 and then another 600 on
top of this one so all in all somewhere
around three to four mil in there I'm
not entirely sure yeah so I went ahead
and added it all up and total we made
4.4 mil off all these merches so not too
shabby and uh yeah right now d-claws
apparently have a pretty good margin so
I'm going to take out my offers for
these and go ahead and hit up the dragon
claws oh my God that was terrible I just
finished my first raid I can't see how
many points I have up there I'll go
ahead and try to show it real quick
let's go to setup I'll take it away and
6.5k points it was so bad
well that was terrible trying to learn
raids by far one of the worst things in
the game this was a 12 man last one I
did 24 but yeah I'm not gonna do the
individual kill count anymore but jeez
it's Christ this is terrible by the way
in the future if anyone is good at raids
or anyone does raids decently and knows
what's going on for the love of God
please add me in the game I want to raid
but I just can't figure it out man start
trying to watch some videos on it or
something so after the first two raid
attempts
um there's a couple things that are
obvious that I need on my account that I
may try and go ahead and knock out of
the way now one of them being void I do
not have any pieces of that it's pretty
AFK so what I think I'm gonna go ahead
and do now is just go get some void and
uh yeah just thank God I just want to go
to bed and I was trying to get my 500th
point and we lost the last two and that
time our night was down to three Health
while one of the poor worlds had 50 and
somehow we survived but Jesus Christ we
are almost halfway done
or wait are we halfway done yeah I think
this marks no [__] the gloves are 150.
all right well we have 500 done we can
go ahead and purchase the top now for
250 okay yeah I mean there was already
yeah oh yes I can confirm it again
so there's the top and now time to go
ahead and get the bottom so this is the
beginning I do also need gloves and then
I also need two Helms so
got a decent way to go but that's where
we are at now going to go ahead and AFK
some more of this tomorrow but with that
said let's go ahead and price check the
bank for this episode and here we are oh
my it's so weird because like whenever I
I don't know who who thought we'd get to
this point though 15 mil cash and just
four spectrals in the inventory just as
merches like how sick is that but yeah
that's what we're currently merging
right now
um right now I could sell them on and
not make any money at all
um obviously not gonna do that they've
recently dipped like 2.5 mil in the last
day so I'm gonna hold on to them and
hopefully they raise overnight but with
that said let's go ahead and get into
the bank value so obviously that's going
to be the most valuable thing in the
bank or most valuable stack but with
that said let's go ahead and get this so
This should do the trick if you guys are
wondering what client I'm using this is
Conduit not a sponsor just have some
pretty cool features so I figured I'd
shout them out go on over to Bank value
and calculate and sometimes it takes a
little bit if you gotta if you got a
decent amount of stuff and there it is
ladies and gentlemen final total of the
bank is
271 mil not too shabby at all and I was
just making sure we did end off last
video with 245 mil meaning in this
episode we made about 26 mil and that is
absolutely six since we're here only
just beginning on the Zora grind along
with all the merches we're about to be
doing but hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video If you guys did make sure to leave
a like if you guys have anything you
guys want to go ahead and tell me make
sure to comment down below if you guys
enjoy the content make sure to subscribe
and yeah with that said hope you guys
have a wonderful day and peace
[Music]
foreign
thank you